so a woman named sasha was filling out
some kind of online application form
recently and shared one part of that
experience on twitter at the section
where it asks for your gender a drop
down menu appears which you can see with
19 options
notice the order of their appearance
agender androgynine bigender demigender
gender fluid genderqueer pangender trans
man trans woman two-spirit gender not
listed declined to answer non-binary and
then cis male and cis female now if
you're wondering for some reason
demigender means somebody who is one
gender but not fully that gender so
perhaps a demigender is 82 man and the
other 18 is comprised of uh you know
other ingredients
human beings now like talk about
themselves like whiskey connoisseurs
might talk about the mash bill in a nice
bottle of bourbon yeah i'm 50 male 20
female uh 20 percent unicorn and uh 10
rye
pan gender by the way is someone who
doesn't connect with any particular
gender
uh but isn't that the same as demigender
and genderqueer and non-binary and
gender fluid and agender aren't these
all labels for the exact same thing
which at bottom is nonsensical in itself
yes of course but in a culture where
labels now take the place of personality
a person wants to accrue all of the
labels they can it's like the kind of
stat padding that a football team might
do in the fourth quarter when they keep
throwing passes even though they're up
by 25 with two minutes left they you
know they want to collect the stats for
their own sake just as the person in the
leftist lgbt cult collects labels for
their own sake
but the striking thing about this array
of options
is not what makes the list but what
doesn't notice what's missing the
options for man and woman not there
these categories have been erased
instead sasha is a biological female who
knows that she is a female and
identifies as what she is has to settle
with the term cis female
but cis is an invented term made up by
the lgbt left with the express purpose
of making normal men and women seem like
one mere variation among an infinite
array of equal if not superior options
by calling normal women cis
you're placing them within the lgbt
framework
you cannot say the word cis male or cis
female in a non-critical way without
affirming every other gender identity
because cis exists in a universe
alongside those others
cis is meant to validate the other
choices while marginalizing itself
the last point is is made the
marginalization point is made in a not
so subtle way
by by listing the cis options last even
though the list is alphabetical
otherwise
so they went outside of the alpha
alphabet alphabet's
alphabetization system there we go in
order to put cis at the bottom because
every other every other term there it's
all it's all alphabetical
and then but we're going to put cis at
the bottom even though it starts with c
kind of a visual representation of the
lgbt identity hierarchy
marginalize normalcy
make normal make normal seem abnormal
that's the goal here
it's a goal that has already been
accomplished largely through the
manipulation of language as always the
manipulation is top down
elites come up with it you know with
these terms they kind of workshop it and
then they send it out into the community
demanding that the plebes adopt it
perfect example of this is the term la
tinx
which i guess they want us to pronounce
as a latin x
but
both no matter how you pronounce it it
makes no sense but really l-a-t-i-n-x
would be la tinc since that's what i'm
calling it
it's the totally incoherent
gender-neutral term for latino that the
lgbt left concocted a few years ago the
daily wire has a report on how well it's
been received in the hispanic community
and uh spoiler alert it has not been
received very well
they report quote on monday morning
politico reported that a new poll
indicated that many hispanic american
voters are bothered by the term la tinx
possibly contributing to the exodus of
hispanic voters from the democrat party
latinx has been introduced in recent
years by academics as a way to describe
hispanic voters without using the
feminine latina or the masculine latino
the national poll was taken between
november 17th and november 21st and
found that the effort to implement
latinx is turning off hispanics
according to politico only two percent
of those polled referred to themselves
as latinx while 68 percent called
themselves hispanic and 21 favored
latino or latina to describe their
ethnic background according to the
survey from bendixon and amondia
international a top democratic firm
specializing in latino outreach
more problematic for democrats 40
percent said latinx bothers or offends
them to some degree and 30 said they
would be less likely to support a
politician who or organization that uses
the term
this latest poll is nearly identical to
a 2019 survey that found 98 percent of
hispanics preferred a term other than
latinx to describe their heritage at the
time the progressive founder of think
now mario karosako
said that uh based on the results he
would advise my colleagues across the
various marketing human resources
journalism and communication disciplines
to avoid using le tanks as a descriptor
for all latinos
well of course normal hispanic people
don't use the term or like it
if spanish is their primary or only
language
then they really can't use the term as
it's as it is unpronounceable in spanish
that's one of the many problems with it
spanish is a gendered language
every noun has a gender
so the word chair in spanish sia is
feminine the word for bench is masculine
el banco
and that's about the extent of the
spanish that i know three years of high
school spanish well spent in any case
the point is that you cannot impose
gender neutrality onto a fundamentally
gendered language without destroying the
language
the left to borrow their phrase is
colonizing the spanish language and
turning it into something else entirely
do you want to impress your uh friends
and family this this holiday well this
is how you do it this is how you get
respect from them which you deserve you
become a lord or a lady which you can do
with established titles and then all of
your friends and family they have to
refer to you that way if they don't they
will be executed it's in it might be
it's somewhere on the certificate it
might not that's that's my own personal
rule i guess established titles is your
opportunity to earn the title of lord or
lady and gain the respect you deserve
all you need is a one square foot plot
of land in scotland established titles
is a project based on historic scottish
custom where landowners are referred to
as lairds or lords and ladies in english
in your title pack you'll receive at
least one square foot of dedicated land
on a private estate and an official
certificate with a crest your
certificate will include a unique plot
number with which you can see the exact
location of your land with the
certificate you could officially change
your name to a lord or lady and get it
on your credit card your plane tickets
etc establish titles is having a great
limited time sale so go to
establishtitles.com
matt walsh to save 10 off today and
remember to use the discount code matt
walsh
or click the link below that's
established titles.com
matt walsh or click the link below so
this goes beyond trying to bully
spanish speaking people into using a new
word they're trying to bully them into a
new language
the irony here is that if for whatever
reason the gendered nature of the word
latino or latina offends you there's
already another inclusive and coherent
and popular term that the people in this
community use almost 70 percent of them
prefer it that is hispanic
so if you want a gender-neutral term for
latino people
why not just call them hispanic
well the answer is that hispanic already
exists
that's the problem
and it's existed for a long time
so when you say the word hispanic you
bring to mind people who live south of
our border
but the lgbt left doesn't want you to
think first of hispanic people when you
talk about hispanic people they want you
to think of themselves
everything and everyone must be defined
by reference to themselves and their
ideology
through le tinx they have essentially
inducted the entire
population of central and south america
all 600 million of them or so into the
lgbt leftist camp
normalcy is pushed further to the
fringes
now the good news at least is that
normal people reject this gibberish
the bad news is that even though nobody
likes it or wants it
still the term exists
and is pushed
and appears in official government
documents
and is used by major corporations
that shows the power of the leftist
elites to obtrude these changes into a
society onto a society against its will
now a few years from now after they have
hectored and threatened and cajoled and
manipulated at least a sizable minority
into using the term
a new political poll will be conducted
showing that hey now would you look at
that 35 percent of hispanics told a
pollster that they prefer the term la
tinx
and when that happens
the left will celebrate the news and
they'll call it progress and evolution
they'll say yeah you look at that
language changes on its own
but it will be neither progress nor
evolution
not a natural evolution anyway
it will be rather the result of a
sustained psychological and social
campaign to change the way people speak
about themselves
and thus the way they see themselves
that as always is the ultimate goal
hey listen
hit the subscribe button do it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated